c'est un super marché d'un nouveau genre
qui a ouvert ses portes samedi dernier à
maurepas paca jean obsolète produits à
date courte esthétique douteuse ici pas
de gâchis ces produits destinés à la
benz ont récupéré et vendu moins cher
une démarche à deux objectifs maintenant
supermarché c'est un concept des
magasins basée sur l'anti gaspillage
donc on répond à deux objectifs
principaux le premier en fait un
objectif écologique on va s'occuper de
récupérer tous les produits écarté du
circuit de grande distribution classique
et le deuxième objectif c'est un
objectif qui est économique en fait nous
on récupère ses produits et on les
revend entre 20 et 50% moins cher que la
grande distribution classique des prix
pouvant être divisé par deux et
l'impression de faire un geste pour
l'environnement de quoi ravir les
clients qui affluent déjà aux portes du
magasin c&a très important qu'il y avait
plus de magasins dans ce sens parce que
comme ça les produits sont pas jetés ils
sont comestibles sont propres c'est
important s'ils sont les cas par exemple
elles sont bonnes et sont pas mal et
voilà croit les cités c'est sans
condition pour faire une soupe si en
plus parce qu'en fait on a des produits
que au lieu de jeter en fin de mandat
qu'il faut qu'on profite parce qu'on
fait des gens valables à bord lancé par
deux jeunes entrepreneurs le magasin
vise les 1200 références sur les 400
mètres carrés du magasin les produits
sont récupérées chez les agriculteurs
les usines les grossistes ou encore les
centrales logistiques les gens font plus
en plus attention à la planète c'est
tous les jours qu'on entend parler et
puis bah le pouvoir d'achat c'est un peu
aussi ses revenus complètement centre ce
sera sur la table donc d'accord on mêle
les deux et qu'on vous propose une offre
qui lie les deux on se dit pourquoi pas
et je pense que les gens ont raison 70%
du magasin est réservé à l'anti
gaspillage contre 30% de fond de rayon
comme le sel ou les pâtes un supermarché
à l'équipe jeunes et à l'ambiance
décontractée qui projette de se
multiplier dans le futur